bonjour messieurs dames je suis heureux
de revenir comme je l'avais promis au
liban d'être si ce soir à beyrouth
comme je m'y étais engagé le 6 août
dernier revenir d'abord pour rendre
compte de l'aide internationale de
l'aide humanitaire qui a suivi
l'explosion et sur laquelle je m'étais
engagé nous avons quelques jours après
le 9 août organisée sous l'égide des
nations unies et de la france
une conférence internationale qui a
permis d'organiser cette aide
avec un souhait qui était la
transparence au travail avec la société
civile
l'implication des organisations non
gouvernementales
j'aurai l'occasion demain de me rendre
aux portes pour faire le point sur ce
sujet faire aussi le point sur
l'ensemble des projets on regardera
également les éléments de coopération
d'urgence en matière sanitaire en allant
à l'hôpital hariri car je n'oublie pas
qu'aujourd'hui aussi le liban est touché
par le cos vite 19 et j'aurai l'occasion
aussi sur les sujets d'école d'éducation
de reconstruction et l'ensemble des
sujets nécessaire de revenir sur le
soutien au peuple libanais c'est là le
même esprit de coopération et le même
engagement qui a présidé aux
coopérations techniques qui ont été les
nôtres depuis un peu plus de trois
semaines aux côtés du gouvernement
libanais à sa demande dans le cadre de
l' enquête sur l'explosion du 4 août
et puis la deuxième raison la visite est
évidemment les 100 ans du grand liban
nous aurons demain le question pas
simplement de commémorer mais d'essayer
d'en tirer toutes les leçons et de nous
projeter vers l'avenir et enfin et
peut-être surtout l'objectif de cette
visite est évidemment de faire un point
d'étape sur la situation politique
ma position est toujours la même c'est
celle de l'exigence sans ingérence
j'ai vu qu'un processus s'était
enclenchée ces dernières heures qui a
permis de faire émerger une figure en
tant que premier ministre il ne
m'appartient aucunement ni de la proue
vignes de la douve et c'est la
souveraineté libanaise qui est ici en
jeu
mais de m'assurer que c'est bien un
gouvernement de mission qui sera formé
au plus vite pour mettre en oeuvre les
réformes que nous connaissons au service
des libanaises et des libanais réforme
des marchés publics de lutte contre la
corruption pour la justice pour la
réforme de l'énergie de l'électricité
pour une meilleure gestion du port pour
une aussi meilleure gestion de la banque
centrale et du système bancaire
autant de réformes indispensables sur
lesquels de mon côté je me suis engagé à
ce que si elles sont prises par le plus
vite possible ce gouvernement de mission
la communauté internationale est
évidemment en premier chef la france
puisse s'engager pour être en soutien du
liban et du peuple libanais voilà les
trois objets de cette visite
au delà du fait que je tenais bien
évidemment à tenir la promesse du 6 août
dernier
voilà mesdames et messieurs merci
beaucoup merci à toutes et tous et
courage merci